hi I'm looking for a patient named
Rachel Klein she's here and dying okay
that's not how we talk out loud in the
hospital are you family or celebrity oh
um celebrity okay we're actually already
checking on that name for pink so you
can go ahead and have a seat next to her
assistant which one is her you look
exactly like pink it's like dogs and
their owners this was me when I first
started whoa
what is that four weeks ago you don't
look like anyone famous did you just
start Oh today's my first day actually
well let me give you some advice
never let your boss get into Ariel
domestics oh don't worry I'm not gonna
be an assistant for long it's not like a
career or anything your loss Pink's
first assistant is now the CEO of her
apparel company oh really
I mean it's just Leah turns for Ariel
gymnastics but she's rich sorry ladies
there's no patient here by the name of
Rachel Kline what uh I want to talk
career with you okay do you know who
Meryl Streep is yeah no I don't because
she's old and old is bad okay young is
good do you know how many views your
video has 15 million it does yeah and
that means I can make you the most
famous person in the world for the next
14 hours well you know I I think I'm
looking for a little bit more longevity
than that I guess I just want like a you
know maybe a small part in a miniseries
or you know a role in a director's hello
hey surely it's Carrie listen I changed
my mind I'm actually gonna need that
video to come down oh can do care Tammy
Larry just called it an affront to
Family Values the gays are back on board
[Music]
wait I'm sorry why isn't there a Rachel
Klein here this happens all the time
it's a dude some middle-aged perv who
wants attention
uwah but then why would he pretend to be
in a hospital they don't think anyone
will actually show they just hope you
feel bad enough to send a bunch of free
craft to their house probably so they
can jack off into it check the return
address says New Jersey exactly where
the pervs live okay but if this keeps
happening why do you keep showing up
here's one time out of 10 it really is a
dying girl and if you don't show up it's
bad optics and pink doesn't do bad
optics she does near-constant aerial
gymnastics well I'm gonna go to New
Jersey and I'm gonna confront this sick
perv you want to come no I have to find
some other Diane kid to take a photo
with
hey are you from that music video oh um
yes but I'd love to do a miniseries one
day like a Fargo or something oh that's
cool um I just wanted to say that I came
out to my mom today sort of because of
that video Oh
I was scared but actually wasn't as bad
as I thought it was gonna be so I guess
this is weird but um thanks that's well
that's that's nice can I give you a hug
or something
sure um okay see ya bye and a good luck
with your miniseries Thanks
chili actually I guess you could leave
the video up I'm okay with it now
too bad care is coming down the AV Club
just said it's no moonlight was it
supposed to be
it doesn't matter Carrie they said it
and now we're hello just what I thought
a pervert excuse me you think you are so
smart
pretending to be a dying girl so what a
teen will send you a t-shirt and you can
nut in it
well here's your little tea perv nut
away oh yeah you should cry oh good all
your little pervert friends are crying
too and they're all in black so Rachel
wasn't at the because she I am so sorry
for your loss yo Bruna hey um you smell
good
got to going out with a bidet night
throwing my junk to stink if she's gonna
be down there you know totally
your uh your dick looks good Thanks so
does yours
what Oh stupid pants
[Music]
what's up here am i doing it wrong no no
no that was that was great I mean it was
a little dry it was kind of like a
turtle eating a carrot but that's not uh
that's not the problem I can't do this
anymore
oh okay cuz every time we do this it's
great or whatever but I just feel like
after oh no you do why because you
don't actually like me and that makes me
feel pathetic okay and I'm not pathetic
I'm a gay icon whoa hey that's cool yeah
since 1:00 this morning yeah
you